[Music]
hello to all so we are at the
forefront of Brittany serval has been in existence since
2003 fifty have made
data decision solutions and above all we are making
digital 3d modeling platforms
or inserting
multi-physics simulation of
our objective  it's actually tubes
used digital twins to
train in fact and specialize
algae au to the real system and therefore the
tooth strong confidence and has always
shown dates to 7.2 specialized and
increase in fact one will use the  i
also for noisy the
optical propagation to change humiliation and
the dates to 7 to have a
huge wide statistical distribution and
in fact to precisely be able to
reproduce cases which in real life
are not reproducible or very
difficult
and
here is therefore confidence  we are
extremely proud that reinforces our
objective to develop synthetic imagery
and we hope to do it in
collaboration with the academy and the  es
rewarding industrial thank you
[Applause]
[Music]